il était un temps où certains yvelinois
parlait une autre langue
au delà des souvenirs il ne reste plus
que quelques rares documents comme cette
monographie de 1898
à l'époque le ministre de l'éducation
nationale commande à ces instituteurs
des études communales en vue de
l'exposition universelle de paris entre
la partie géographique et historique
monsieur bel homme maître d'école à
follainville petit village yvelinois de
776 ham semble étonné par le patois
mantois
apparemment les habitants des formes en
fait beaucoup de mots et là il explique
par exemple que la lettre a et prononcé
avec le son de la lettre o on dit une
potée une pauvre euros etc qui ressemble
beaucoup
un vieux français en satin une façon
ancienne de parler le français
avec des diot à la place de haut avec
des accents plus aiguës graves au milieu
du 19e siècle la ville de
mantes-la-jolie compte environ 3500
habitants
le chemin de fer ne traverse pas encore
la commune mais le parler populaire qui
est bien installé au grand désarroi du
sous préfet armand cassan qui rédige un
ouvrage consacré à la ville en 1833
il porte un jugement assez assez sévère
sur sur ses particularités locales 1
qu'il parle qu'il décrit comme autant de
vices et d expression assez forte il en
quad d'expression koroturk encore les
termes assez fort il va même jusqu'à
parler de barbarisme de l'ignorance
depuis cet autre temps ses intonations
sont d'avoir disparu le beta est
redevenu le bétail lents comme l'alcool
le mantois ne fera donc pas partie des
langues régionales reconnu par la charte
européenne charte que l'état doit encore
adopter